good morning good afternoon and good
evening everyone depending on your time
zone my name is luzia chadima and i will
be the sessions host
our speaker today is christopher ariza
talking about why date times means you
need units to to avoid the year 2262
problem that we're going to have for our
great great great grand cause we're
going to
uh christopher ariza is cto at research
affiliates focused on investment
strategies and research his background
is slightly different he comes from the
music area he got a degree in music at
mit and
did some more research in that area so
i'm really curious how his path was from
music to going straight
deep into python programming with date
times which is an area i'd rather not
work in because it sometimes can be
quite tricky to deal with that
but please take it away
great thank you for the introduction so
as covered in the title what we're going
to talk about today is uh daytime
formats in particular the numpy datetime
64 format so i have three motivations
for talking about this with you all
today
the first is there's a lot of confusion
out there about the various date time
formats that exist we have the numpy
datetime 64 and we have the python date
time and there's a lot of confusion
about those what is the difference
between those two formats we also have
some other things around like the pandas
timestamp object which also can lead to
some confusion
the second motivation is in many years
of working with pandas i discovered some
curious behaviors for example
nanoseconds would be appear everywhere
without me understanding why those
nanoseconds were there
furthermore i would find my colleagues
using maximum dates of 2262 in various
places and and that seemed very strange
third for many years now i've been
involved in creating an alternative to
pandas called static frame a alternative
data frame library that enforces
immutable data
and in approaching the implementation of
this i took a different approach to
implementing index objects and
supporting date time 64 arrays with
units and that also sort of motivated me
wanting to
share my work in that area in this
presentation
so my title references a year 2262
problem which
is not going to happen anytime soon but
is a useful case for us to look at so
some of you will remember the year 2k
problem this was the issue where
systems around the world were using two
characters to represent dates and the
fear was that 1999 would advance to 1900
well the y 2262 problem is kind of
similar what will happen is uh a date at
april 11th 2262 if advanced one more day
beyond that will overflow or raise an
exception
so this is not obviously an immediate
danger but the y2262 problem illustrates
a data type misuse in pandas and it's
caused by the exclusive use of
nanoseconds for all daytime 64
representations now it doesn't have to
be this way we can use appropriate units
with datetime 64 to get a broader range
to get dates before 1677 and after 2262.
and by specifying the unit of a daytime
64 we can take more advantage of
encoding a resolution and get more
narrow typing
so in looking at why daytimes need units
we're going to first compare the python
date time with the numpy daytime 64.
we're going to look at some performance
comparisons between these two talk about
how to convert them and look at date
times and pandas and static frame
so first we need to understand how can
we encode date time as data there's two
basic representations in wide use
first we can store integers for year
months date seconds et cetera i'll call
this a partitioned representation
another approach is to store an offset
from an anchor and overwhelmingly the
most common anchor is the unix epoch
this is uh january 1st 1970. so the way
that these representations work is we
store um a unit some sort of unit maybe
seconds or some other unit from the unix
epoch and i'll call this an offset
representation
so when we look at the python date and
date time types these are partitioned
representations and we can think of date
and date time as the same kind of thing
but with different units with date we
have integers for year month and day
with date time we have integers for year
month and we keep going all the way down
to microseconds
the numpy datetime 64 implementation is
something very different it's an offset
representation so it's going to use
values in a signed in 64 way and it's
going to interpret those as offsets and
the size of that offset is given by the
unit
so numpy's daytime 64 supports 13 offset
units from year all the way to ato
seconds
as i talk about these it gets kind of
confusing so when i refer to date time
i'm referring specifically to python's
date and date time objects and we import
those from the date time module when i
refer to date time 64 i'm explicitly
referring to the numpy datetime 64
either arrays or elements and we import
those from numpy as
np so both numpy and python support time
delta objects in addition to date time
objects time deltas as might be easily
unexpected are always represented with
an offset with python we can have time
deltas from week all the way down to
microsecond and
in numpy we have time deltas available
across the full range of all 13 units
there
okay so next we're going to compare date
time and daytime 64 as a way to help us
understand their differences
so first we'll look at constructors
when we create a date time a python date
time object we provide that exact
partitioned representation that is the
underlying representation of the object
in addition date time has broad support
for parsing strings and other
representations
with numpy's date time 64 we can provide
an offset as an integer and a unit
alternatively we can provide a string
using a very specific iso string
representation
numpy state time 64 does not support as
wide a range of string representations
as python state time
and we can create both daytime 64 arrays
and elements we'll see examples of these
so when we create a
python date object as many of us are
familiar we provide each of the
partitioned values the year the month
and the day we can also use alternative
constructors to provide values as
strings or to provide our own parsers
and this is a huge power of the python
date and date time
functions is that we can parse arbitrary
string representations of dates
we can also produce a date from an
offset to the epoch which as i've
already mentioned is how numpy's daytime
64 representation works
looking at numpy daytime 64 we can
create a daytime 64 by giving an offset
and a unit and that's exactly what we're
doing here this will give us one uh
offset of unit size date after the epoch
which as you might expect is january 2nd
1970.
we can also provide an iso string
representation of dates and date times
and numpy is able to parse those and
give us the appropriate object back now
we can do the same thing when we want to
create an array here i give a tuple of
string dates and i tell numpy to just
interpret these as date times 64. here
i'm not giving a unit but numpy properly
identifies these as date units
uh alternatively i can even give a tuple
of integers and a unit and numpy will
figure out these are day offsets from
the 1970 january 1st epoch
so moving on we can consider the
resolution of each of these types so
with date time and python's date object
we have each type offers only one unit
uh data and the data resolution may not
be the same as the unit and i'll give
you an example of what that means
with datetime64 we have one type that
supports all 13 units from year to ad
second and the data resolution because
we have more types can actually be the
same as the unit and i think that's an
important consideration
so when we think when we create a python
date object and we look at the
resolution we see that it tells us the
resolution is one day
but here i create a date time and i've
only provided data up to the level of
minute and i look at the resolution and
the resolution is microseconds the
resolution is always interpreted as the
minimum unit of the date time type
now with uh numpy's datetime 64 we can
do more we can specify
a date time 64 across a wide range of
units and that unit is encoded in the d
type here we see a year and a month d
type they encode the unit and we have
much more granularity of our units so
that the resolution of our data can
actually be reflected in the unit of the
d type
okay what about the range so
the date time and date objects
arbitrarily set their range from year
one to year 99.99 now i say this is
arbitrary because python's integers can
support a much broader range than this
this is a hard-coded constraint in the
implementation of these types with date
time 64 the range is controlled
by the
unit we desire and the underlying type
which is an n64 smaller units thus have
smaller ranges
so if we look at a uh python date time
object we see the max of the min is from
year 999 to year one for both date times
and dates
with date time 64 we have a lot of
different ranges available to us
depending on our unit so if we quickly
get the minimum and maximum integer on a
signed into 64 we can use those values
to show us with different units what our
maximum value will be so if we create a
date time 64 with the maximum integer
and say the unit is a date we can see we
get this astronomical year
far far into the future
if we use that same max n64 integer and
we convert it to microseconds we get uh
similarly well not as similar but also a
very large year if we interpret the same
value as nanoseconds now we get a year
that we should recognize 2262 april 11.
in numpy's documentation they provide a
nice table of all of the ranges of these
units going all the way from year to ato
second and as expected as the unit gets
smaller the time pan the time span gets
smaller as well
okay what about converting between these
units well with date time we can uh
create a new object by using a method or
a constructor with datetime 64 we want
to use the as type method and that will
allow us to go between any unit we need
so
if we have a date object and we want to
convert it to date time we simply need
to unpack the partitioned values if we
have a date time object and we want to
go to date we can simply use the date
method for date time 64 we have a huge
range of flexibility simply by using as
type here i have a daytime 64 of minutes
i simply want to as type this to months
i just provide a datetime 64
representation with the appropriate unit
and numpy handles the
conversion for me as needed
now what about shifting well with the
date time we can only use time delta
objects to shift
and using non-day unit time deltas with
date objects truncates that information
i'll show you exactly what i mean by
that with date time 64 we can use
operator overloading to add and subtract
units with integers which is pretty
convenient um and we can use any time
delta 64 with any date time 64 and
implicitly get the right and appropriate
unit without losing information
so if we go if we look at shifting a
date time object we cannot shift a date
with an integer we have to use a time
delta
if we have a date object a python date
object and we shift it by a time delta
that has a microseconds notice those
microseconds are ignored that's quite
different than what numpy will do with a
similar move
if we apply that time delta to a date
time then those microseconds are
observed as expected
if we shift a daytime 64 well here we
can actually shift by an integer we can
shift by an integer because the unit
tells us what that integer means and
here that integer is interpreted as a
single day we shift january 2nd to
january 3rd
if i have a nanosecond level array and i
shift it by 20 well that's going to
shift each date by 20 nanoseconds and
notice that the type of the array has
changed to be a nanosecond
representation and that's the same thing
i show here where i have dates and i
combine them with nanoseconds we get a
nanosecond array
what about missing time uh well the date
time and date objects do not offer
specialized objects for missing time we
just would use none to serve as a
placeholder whereas with datetime 64 we
have nat not a time which is a nan like
value that can live in date time 64
arrays
so
those nat values come from nuns or empty
strings in the creation of a daytime 64
array so here i create an array i say i
want daytime 64 dates and i provide none
as my value this is going to get
converted to an nat the same thing
happens if i provide an empty string
and nats propagate just like nands under
transformation so if i have an array
with an nat and i perform a time delta
on it
that is going to propagate the nat in
the expected position
okay what about the performance of these
different types of
representations
so
you might think why can't we just put
date time objects in object arrays um
well object arrays uh in order for
daytime objects to live in object arrays
numpy's going to have to unbox each of
those objects and perform operations on
them that's going to be considerably
slower than what we can do with
contiguous data when we have date time
64 arrays what we have are c arrays with
contiguous bytes and that's always going
to give us much better performance
so i'm going to do some performance
comparisons you can find these in the
static frame repository if you want to
look at these or run them yourself we're
going to experiment with about 11 000
dates and i've created two arrays a
datetime 64 array and an object array of
date time objects and if we look at the
performance of these guys we see that
daytime 64 is is always going to be
faster so if we want to find the year of
our array of date time objects we can
just look at the year attribute and put
that in a list comprehension if we
compare that to doing an as type
operation the ad the daytime 64 is going
to be about six times faster
if we want to find all of the dates that
are mondays and produce a boolean array
we can do that with python date objects
by simply calling the weekday method and
comparing it to zero we can do the same
thing with the date time 64 by treating
by transforming the integers such that
zero is monday and doing the comparison
at the level of num of a numpy array and
this is going to be about nine times
faster than working with the python
objects
another common move is we need to do a
comparison we need to split an array of
dates into two groups uh if we do that
move with uh date time objects we can do
something like this with a date time 64
array we can use this move and that's
going to be about 11 times faster
finally if we want to shift the days in
an array to do this with date objects we
would need to create a time delta object
and shift each date one at a time
the similar move using a datetime 64
array we simply need to add one and we
get exactly what we need uh and that is
going to be 60 times faster so there we
really see the benefit of using
contiguous data in a proper datetime 64
array
so what about converting between these
two types what about going from daytime
64 to date time and vice versa well
moving from daytime 64 to date time
there might be some challenges because
date time 64 is has a more broad range
and we're moving to a more narrow range
so some units will restore result in
distorted or transformed values
the way to do this is to simply use uh
the to list method or convert the array
to an object array
now day through microsecond units
convert naturally to date and date time
objects correctly but units of year and
month convert to date and smaller than
microsecond units convert to offset
integers both of those may not be what
you expect so here we have a numpy array
of date time 64 days and we're going to
ask type these to object and we see that
numpy nicely gives us back date objects
and nothing is lost
we can do the same thing by going to
list but if we have date time 64 months
and we convert those to objects we're
actually going to get date objects we're
going to introduce a day here that we
didn't have before and the same thing
happens with years so that's something
to watch out for
um
if we want to try to convert a
nanosecond or anything lower than
microsecond to object uh we're going to
see that numpy is going to give us back
integers these are the raw offsets um
and this is likely to be an undesirable
situation
going from daytime to date time 64 is
quite straightforward here all we need
to do is take our values and as type
them to the appropriate datetime 64
representation
okay so what we often do with our date
times is we're using them to label data
and we can do this in pandas and we can
do this in static frame
and pandas and static frame take very
different approaches here so pandas
provides one datetime index type the
datetime index and it forces all
datetime 64s to become nanosex
nanoseconds regardless of
what you ask for staticframe has one
index type per daytime 64 unit
and we can use datetime64 units to
explicitly specify our resolution and
our type
so in pandas every datetime 64 is a
nanosecond pandas stores all values as
nanosecond daytime 64 arrays you don't
have a choice any daytime 64 array given
as an index or given as values is
converted to nanoseconds without without
asking you uh we also have this
pd timestamp object which allows a
nanosecond resolution in the object
domain
so
why use nanoseconds everywhere a few of
us use data at the nanosecond resolution
and using nanosecond resolution
compromises the range of more common
units like dates
and using nanosecond resolution forces
the creation of this pd.timestamp object
and again we have an option to align
with python's microsecond unit in its
own date time but that option was not
taken
so let me show you an example of this so
if we have if we create a series here
with a date time index and here i'm
specifically giving date objects i'm
saying the resolution of my data is at
the level of date we can create a series
this way and things look fine when we
just look at the series but if we look
at the underlying array in the index we
can see that it's been converted to
nanoseconds
um and if you're a reminder you have
about two minutes left okay thank you
and if we convert this to object uh we
see we get a timestamp object um we can
as type this at the level of the array
and we get the expected integer offsets
um and it doesn't matter how we put the
nanosecond array in the pandas container
if we put the array in as a raw index
pandas is going to convert it to a
nanosecond fluoresce if we put it in as
the actual values pandas is also going
to convert it to a nanosecond
with static frame we've taken a very
different approach we have an index type
per unit so we have a family of index
types this encourages the specification
of a resolution it allows us to take
full advantage of the available range
and we don't have a need for pd
timestamp so static frame offers this
full family of index types one per unit
and when we create
containers when we create labels we can
specify the intended resolution so if i
have some monthly data i can create an
index year month and that information
that resolution is retained and we can
see under the hood we have a daytime 64
month array uh backing this data
if i want to represent the dates of the
magna carta or when martin luther posted
his 95 theses i can do that and i can
create an index date object with dates
in 12 15 and 15 17. this cannot be
represented in pandas and if i try to
create a series with these values pandas
will complain that they are out of
bounds and again that is because pandas
has chosen to represent everything as a
nanosecond
so to summarize in attempting to
simplify the date time 64 by only using
nanosecond units pandas creates a more
complexity by introducing this weird
timestamp object limits the usable range
for common use cases like dates and is
forced to do unit transformations behind
your back
i'm not the only one to have been
confused by this
this stack overflow post from about
eight years ago asks about how to
convert amongst these various types
wes mckinney the original creator of
pandas answers welcome to hell uh uh
clearly expressing uh frustration with
the complexity that exists in panda's
handling of daytime 64.
so in summary
use daytime 64 units and in doing so you
can do a lot more in encoding your
resolution so you get unambiguous
resolution specification we can know
whether we have a monthly time series or
something else we can take advantage of
larger ranges we don't not everything is
a nanosecond and we can use dates before
1677 and after 2262
and we permit more narrow typing and i
believe more narrow typing gives more
maintainable code the unit becomes part
of the d type we can make explicit our
intended resolution and we avoid doing
any behind the back degradation of
information
so i encourage you all to uh explore
daytime 64. we should use daytime 64
over object arrays of daytime i've shown
that's always going to be faster we can
use daytime 64 units to express
resolutions everything is not a
nanosecond nor should it be and finally
static frame's daytime index family
might make your code more maintainable
by giving you explicit definition of the
resolution of your data
thank you